vendredi à trois rivières au lendemain
du 16e débat des chefs de sa carrière
gilles duceppe est accueilli en héros
par 80 militants raison début de
campagne
on est parti devant la face on va finir
le vent dans le dos vous pouvez compter
sur moi témoin
chez qui peut compter sur vous merci
gilles duceppe sait trop bien que le
vent doit tourner avec seulement deux
députés sortants et des sondages encore
plus bas que lors de sa dégelée de 2011
le bloc québécois est menacée
d'extinction alors le chef met les
bouchées doubles et son autobus avale
les kilomètres à bord ou les
journalistes affectés aux blocs sont
rares gilles duceppe travaille beaucoup
il peaufine ses discours
accompagné de sa femme et de son équipe
rapprochée
ce jour la direction québec gilles
duceppe visite le bureau de deux de ses
candidats pour motiver ses troupes lors
des visites jamais de foule
mais des partisans convaincus on croise
vraiment mathieu militant de longue date
ils ne sont pas de ferveur entourant la
campagne du bloc mais lui aussi reste
optimiste je compte à pasquier l'eau il
devrait aller chercher des
circonscriptions de tous les chefs
gilles duceppe est celui qui prend le
plus de temps pour rencontrer les
citoyens un peu partout quel que soit
leur âge les québécois le salut et
semble apprécié coup franc
elle vous êtes l'accueil est très
chaleureux partout moissac you il ya
toujours un mot qui revient d'un cadre
est ce que les gens disent c'est merci
d'être venus bruno pilote a travaillé à
toutes les campagnes de gilles duceppe
au bloc québécois
je pense pas qu'on se bat pour survivre
on est là parce qu'on y croit
cette année les gens écoutent alors que
cette année les gens nous posent des
questions et les gens nous regardent
franchement ce qui n'était plus le cas
dans les dernières semaines de la
campagne de 2011
mais cet intérêt pour le bloc et son
chef se traduira-t-il en vote
voilà la grande question quand même le
bloc défend les intérêts des québécois
vraiment l'eau pas plus que les autres
parties du chemin certains points non je
pense pas que c'est peine perdue mais je
suis pas certaine que ça va donner des
très bons résultats
alors ce mot veut dire qu'on va débattre
comme tout le monde je suis beaucoup de
sympathie pour monsieur du cern en même
temps il ya des considérations plus lui
disant d'un autre niveau qui vont
rentrer un jour maman 3ds que la
campagne du blog vous intéresse
néanmoins sincèrement plus ou moins
pourquoi le pouvoir parce que vraiment
on veut que nos choix ya un impact pour
donc c'est je crois que si on peut lire
un gouvernement qui peut changer les
choses mais vraiment à l'ensemble du
pays
vous avez chéquier premier les pommes
tambre mais je suppose que c'est vous
qui allez les rangs mention de
l'impression que les conservateurs sont
dans de ramasser des pommes que fait
tomber de l'arbre gnp date un faux
compte nous devons y reste trois
semaines
partout où il passe gilles duceppe
répète que le vrai vote stratégique sera
d'envoyer le plus de députés possible du
bloc à ottawa
la tacle et le [ __ ] sur toutes les
tribunes je pense que plus en plus les
québécois et les québécoises réalise que
le npd est resté muet hasina pas
défendre nos intérêts du québec
souhaitant donner l'exemple ce samedi à
mascouche
j'ai du cep participent à une
manifestation contre le projet d'oléoduc
de transcanada qui passerait par le
québec
par temps venteux qui doit décider
on s'adresse aux jeunes intelligents au
coeur des gens ceux des enjeux et
démontrer comment nos réponses faire de
beaucoup d autres partis une fois par
semaine le dimanche gilles duceppe fait
du porte à porte dans son comté
montréalais de laurier sainte marie où
il a perdu par plus de 5000 voix il y a
quatre ans regrettera t-il sa décision
d'être revenu en politique s'il perd le
19 octobre
il ne veut même pas y penser encouragé
par l'affection des québécois il
continue sa campagne sur les routes de
la province avec énergie et conviction
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal